more on how the partial reopening of
states could affect the fight against
the virus here we're joined by our chief
medical correspondent that's dr. Jon
LaPook Jon LaPook good morning to you I
broke it I went out after 32 days
morning I went out on Saturday I was
gonna go out on Sunday I saw the number
of people out there I freaked out a
little bit and said nope not going out
so let's start with the basics what
should people keep in mind once you
venture outside you know Gail I spoke to
the CDC last night about this and they
are adamant they're hammering home the
point that it's not a free pass going
outside even if you're in a place where
they're opening up you still have to do
all the things that everybody's telling
you to do the social distancing the face
mask and absolutely you need to continue
to wash your hands I mean it's so easy
because it's an invisible threat you're
not seeing it but I like what dr. Burke
said which is you know you don't want to
get infected yourself and then even if
you have no symptoms pass it on to
Grandma so John if we're just outside
walking around if you bump into each
other could you could you get the virus
that way just a random bumps that's what
I was worried about is it that dangerous
and you know we're still learning things
about the aerosolization you know how
much to what extent is it little
particles in the air but in general the
advice from the infectious disease
experts from the CDC has been it has to
be prolonged contact and specifically I
remember asking them you know what about
you just walking on in Central Park you
walk by somebody and you happen to be
four feet away not six feet away that's
not what people are most concerned about
that's not what drives infections
there's this sort of casual contact it's
more prolonged contact where you're
within six feet for some prolonged
period of time certainly more than four
seconds well what's your message you see
people are getting very restless they're
they're closing in on each other some
people are even using the phrase it's
assault on our civil rights when we're
being told that we can't go outside
what's your message to people that that
don't think social distancing is
necessary and that we need to get out of
the house you know this is a general
this is a time when we need to be
thinking about society as a whole not
about ourselves individually you know I
spoke to dr. Tom Ingoldsby last night
he's the infectious disease expert from
Hopkins and he was really interesting
about how he described that it could be
reasonable to start thinking about
opening up but you want to do it
logically in areas for example states
with that don't have a lot of infections
Vermont Montana Alaska and if you're
gonna do that opening up do it carefully
you need to have enough testing to know
what's going on and you also have to
have enough boots on the ground and
public health officials so that if you
do notice that there's an infection to
isolate the person figure out who their
contacts are and do all the standard
public health measures that we've always
done over the years that are
tried-and-true it all boils down to the
testing John one question if you need
one question answer to better understand
the virus what is it for you just the
one it's the question that we don't know
that is gonna be asked tomorrow
seriously every day there's something
new that comes out a new problem the
problem smelling problem with clotting
problem that we didn't predict so I
think the problem here is we don't even
know the questions to ask right now but
I sure would like to know what the arc
of this is going to be yeah you and me
both everybody listening what's that
question thank you very much John the
poop